droht dem indischen ozean jetzt die mega
ölkatastrophe das havarierte frachter
cassio dass er tagen vor mauritius öl
verliert droht in zwei teile zu
zerbrechen
1180 tonnen schweröl haben das
türkisblaue wasser und die schneeweißen
strände des inselparadies bereits
verseucht nach bild-informationen riss
ein bereits leer gepumpt der tank
versuche den frachter wieder flott zu
machen scheiterten
mehr als 1000 480 tonnen öl wurden
eingesammelt oder aus dem schiff gepumpt
doch die katastrophe ist kaum noch
aufzuhalten noch immer sind 1800 tonnen
treibstoff in den tanks die nun geleert
werden sollen bevor die ölkatastrophe
zum super-gau wird wwf experte jörn
ehlers zu bild radfahren mit schweröl
einem besonders giftigen treibstoff der
an land gar nicht mehr verbrannt werden
darf
es ist überfällig dass man diese schwere
verbietet durch andere treibstoffe
ersetzt
mit besen und schaufeln versuchen
inselbewohner ihre strände vom ölteppich
zu befreien
iwf-experten ehlers seien die
einheimischen darauf nicht vorbereitet
gewesen obwohl allein im juli 2000
frachter vorbeigefahren sind